the White House is fighting a brand new
battle to combat internal leaks
president Trump taken to Twitter to
blast staffers for the latest wave of
unauthorized media disclosures the so
called leaks coming out of the White
House are a massive over-exaggeration
put out by the fake news media in order
to make us look as bad as possible
without being said leakers are traitors
and cowards and we will find out who
they are top White House adviser
Kellyanne Conway is also warning that
big changes are coming and that these
leakers could soon be kicked to the curb
there are all kinds of leaks some leaks
exist to hurt I guess colleagues
suddenly meets exists because they
disagree with the policies that are
being put forth but none of them are
helpful and I will tell you this
something else that's going on in this
White House but not as badly as it was
at the beginning where it's not so much
leaking as using the media to shove each
other if you work at the pleasure of the
President as we all do here and you have
the privilege and the blessing of coming
today every today every work in this in
this White House on behalf of the nation
to expect personnel changes as a result
I do actually yes I do
okay so strong words coming not only
from the president but from his staffers
I'm Jesse as it relates to the leaks
he's very frustrated because obviously
at a time like this you want to be
focusing on accomplishment goals
campaign promises fulfilled all the
positive things that have been coming
out of the White House but then you have
these leaks which makes it frustrating
miss Comey says there's a lot of weasel
moves being made in the Trump White
House and there's a reason for that
a few reasons President Trump brings out
the best and the worst in people cos he
encourages competition with his staff so
some people leak when they feel they're
down and they need to move up he also
being an outsider businessman brought in
a thousand different factions he brings
in family he brings in loyalists the
campaign people the insiders the
military the ideologues and I net
ideologues when you have that many
different factions are going to have a
diversity of opinion also Trump devours
TV and print media obviously so one of
the ways you influence him it's either
leaked or do TV hits he's also a talker
so he talks to a thousand people a days
on the phone he's calling people and
he's extremely emotional and passionate
and speaks very colorfully and bluntly
so a lot of times after you hear the
president you can't resist the urge to
leak because it's so money you can't
believe what the president said can you
believe he said this and then people are
inspired to leak it's true
so money also the institution raised
from like 1990 winners and also the
institution's in DC they're not always
in love with the president he ran
against these institutions we know Comey
himself hated Trump personally the FBI
people too and Comey leaked in order to
trigger the special counsel I think
Kelly has gotten a hold on it it's it
was started as a Niagara Falls now it's
like half of Niagara Falls but it's
still bad in the same sense Trump
utilizes the leaks because he can say
now look at the fake news media and he
can try to diminish their credibility at
the same time there is fake news there's
legit leaks but there is fake news
because you have these sources that are
unnamed unverified unsubstantiated
coming from third-rate players and have
access to grinds and they feed the press
and the press spends it negative the
Obama White House you never had this
problem no one leaked because they were
on the same side as the press so
everything that came out of the Obama
White House was spin and it was spun
positively for Obama all right well
there you go a water log for you all
right Dana please try to match that okay
so when I was there I would say that if
the White House communications team was
on the front page of the paper or
leading the five house a bit mortified
because you don't want to be the news
you want the president to be the news
and he is the news and because he this
is also just a part of him the other way
to look at this though is that if we are
leading the show with this news that
must mean that things are pretty good
elsewhere I mean we're not leading it
with any other sort of dramatic thing
but we're going to talk about Israel and
Gaza in the next block so
do you think that there's a big problem
I think that a lot of people believe
that if they're talking to somebody in
the media and you get a little bit of a
thrill when you see yourself quoted even
if it's anonymously because you know
that somebody thinks you're important so
those reporters keep going back they're
not fake they're actually journalists
who are reporting the story the
president calls them traitors and I
would assume in a small group like the
one that they had where the McCain
comments leaked out about Kelly Sadler
they probably know who it is I do think
it's interesting though that some Maggie
Haberman of the New York Times one of
them her tweet yesterday was that
sometimes the people complaining most
about the leaks are actually the leakers
so I don't know who's getting fired
I always been my my experience that the
person that usually complains the first
and the loudest is the leaker so
interesting or shall we say muy
interesante mm-hmm yeah very good so
what do you make of this what is he
gonna do to the leakers I don't know I
I'm not sure if it's a leak but you know
I think about my experience working in
magazines and stuff and stories that get
out a lot of a lot of leaks like people
don't actually call up a reporter they
usually vent or they go to a bar and
they talk loudly this is what I do
that's what I do
I and and so what happens is what -
Jesse spent all this like interesting
stuff is coming out I like trumpets
Trump is the show
he's the show so people come out and
they talk about stuff and then that gets
picked up and I it's a it's happened to
me a lot of times when I used to work in
magazines I would tell somebody a story
and then it would be in the magazine go
like why did I tell that to that guy
because he got drunk and then he told
somebody else and then and that ends up
in in page six and I'm you know then I
got explain myself the Pinot Noir game I
know that's but it I do think that I
think that's what it is I think it's
people venting and people gossiping but
I don't think it's actually deliberately
because I just don't think that one I
thought I just went one about Senator
McCain I think seems like a deliberate
no I think somebody walked out and was
just disgusted by the joke disgusted by
the joke walked
outside cause that I can't believe you
didn't call a reporter but said like
said to somebody else you wouldn't
believe what this person said that's
like three sources though well maybe it
was they probably backed it up but yeah
I mean listen obviously he has to do
something to make sure if you have
people and they are talking and it's
just kind of productive to a positive
work environment one in terms of it for
any administration whether it was an
Obama administration or Clinton or Bush
or with president trumping trying to
focus on goals and objectives and world
peace this is a distraction well this is
a this is Kabuki theater because it
seems to me on so many levels what we're
dealing with here today is the fallout
from the nasty comment about Senator
McCain and people say oh my god this is
a leak this is terrible
guess what the real problem here is what
was said and then the failure to
apologize publicly for it and so it's
kind of like well let's throw up the fog
let's put on the shoes and the act and
the mass and what pretends that's not
the story the story is the leaks
well the leaks have been there all along
I was just curious about leaks well just
remember just it was just last week I
think that the president maybe it was
this week things go so quickly the
president was tweeting about this
Chinese company and the negotiators who
were trying to make a deal on trade with
China said we didn't know about where'd
that come from why is that in the papers
how're you think about something like
you know going back his light schedule
in the mornings his executive time you
say that's a leak oh gee I don't know
Rob port or John Kelly how about his his
nasty comment about people coming from
Africa the Caribbean El Salvador how
about just last week Kirsten Nielsen
they said Oh Kirsten Nielsen wasn't
gonna resign oh but then john kelly says
yeah i called her and asked her not to
resign all right why you drifted so far
apart from what this is about this is
exactly what you are the one who is off
in space and this is what it's about is
i'd lead you to explain that to me wrong
well i am i often space because this
explain is about the white house trying
to change the story greg the white house
does not want to focus on what it's that
was said about Senator McCain they want
us instead to pretend like oh poor
president Trump is under so Kay
by his enemies who are leaked
responded to watch that's exactly what
I'm trying to respond to so you don't
have to say I'm off in space what I'm
trying to what the point the important
point here you have to separate the
elements the leak from the leaking okay
right the leak which is a joke that was
told in private that's a separate story
and you could be upset one about
something that is said privately or
off-camera that suddenly ends up in the
press wand because that has happened to
you and it has happened to me and it has
happened to a lot of people when you say
something and all of a sudden it becomes
a big story because somebody leaked it
so the point of this story is it about
the item itself which is the joke it is
about how something private becomes a
public story that's what it's about
that's what this about the president is
upset that he can have a seek private
counsel or have a private conversation
without people leaking it anyone would
be frustrated with that that's the point
of this whole segment they're saying
they're not going to drawing the line on
this general Kelley took people's phones
away I don't know what they're doing
hand signals whatever point is stuff is
getting out and that's counterproductive
well one of the real dangers too is that
it does run the risk of chilling
conversation that's the point you if you
go into a meeting you're in the
Roosevelt Room and you need to kick
around I asked for a policy time you
don't want to be the one who says like
I'm afraid to say something in this
meeting like and I'm not honestly I'm
not gonna make a comment like that about
Senator McCain but I say you're saying I
don't think that's a good idea because
XY and Z and you just like shooting the
breeze and you're like brainstorming and
that's gonna be in the paper it does run
the risk of the president not getting
his appointees best advice could I
answer that though I want to add to that
one hold on Juan I want to add to that I
do think that what your point about
conversation being chilled is an
important one but there's also something
that we all have to admit that we tell
stick jokes and we have told them
privately no I know I can I can do it
everybody tells a sick joke privately
they may not remember that they did but
they have we are setting a dangerous
precedent all my favorite people are
tasteless that's what's interesting
about this is that somebody in the room
took and because is it distrust whatever
it is that they don't
somebody in the room that people willing
to go out and do that that is what that
is actually a bigger Institute you can
say you could say the joke is awful but
it wasn't a joke it was a bad joke it
wasn't nobody has to accept you Hill
described it as a joke that's least
about dead is nobody took it as a joke
it wasn't reported as a joke but let me
do an accurate point my point to you is
we know the president talks a great deal
right he talks to people here at Fox
News apparently regularly right now who
are you replied oh I think I can rub
somebody I can think I can go either way
on either side of me but it just seems
to me that what you get here is people
who are in the know and who are strong
Republicans the karl rove saying the
president is the biggest leaker of all
right because he talks oh he talks but
what i'm saying is when you talk about
people having confidence these are
trump's people he brought these people
in and then all of a sudden we are
having a dinner like oh gee the poor
president poor president what are you
talking about I never said poor
president mine is transparent so if you
know any leaks he leaks on Twitter
everybody's feeling and by the way he's
the president he's the owner in the
keeper of the information so if he wants
to talk to our reporter whether it's
Maggie Haberman or whether he wants to
talk to somebody and Rudy Giuliani
whatever this is what he does it's how
he operates how he does business I think
a lot of Fallon watches a lot of people
think that there needs to be some
historical record kept because things
are so strange right now in the White
House what there should be a record
because it's strange
yeah people want the historical record
to be clear I mean it's like the phone
call with the Austrian member in the
prince oh no problem with that call for
the Australian Prime Minister turned out
there was a big problem big problem and
that somebody leaked it because they
wanted the world to know this is the way
he talks to her out I've been I've
witnessed things said in this company by
people who didn't think it was ever
going to be public but somebody said it
I was profound thank you